118 days fighting for his life
nine court attempts to keep him alive
archie battersby's mother holly dance
says this latest decision feels
different
absolutely deflate is just so let down
yeah obviously that was our last option
um
with regards to even the fact that
we've been offered
help from other countries you know
they're not even prepared to shift on
that
and we've now got a fight to see whether
we can get them out of here to have a
dignified
passing at a hospice
it's just it's unfair
tonight she dreads what the hospital
bosses will decide about when arch's
life support treatment will end
he's good
he's been good all along that's the most
heartbreaking thing about it you know i
wish i could
take you all in there to see
like for yourself
it's just unfair
the fact is apparent we've got no rights
with our children it's disgusting
holly dance has fought bart's health nhs
trust in a remarkable case that started
with a fight over whether archie should
have a brain stem test to be legally
declared dead and culminated in legal
arguments about the uk's international
treaty obligations
obviously it was a strategic decision
that was taken
by lawyers acting for the family to go
to to the un first rather than to go
straight to the european court of human
rights so
they went to the un um treaty body
responsible for
for implementation or overseeing
implementation
of of the convention for the protection
of persons with disabilities and so they
they received a positive ruling
in that which the uk then said that they
would not implement
in months of hearings holly's stance
never changed all she asked was for time
for archie to recover she points to the
case of lewis roberts
declared brain stem dead last year but
just hours before his organs were to be
donated
lewis breathed by himself
this is him last week playing football
it was like it was out of our control no
matter what we said it was just did it
make a difference at that point
i just feel horrendous for the family or
folks it's taken out of their hands
isn't it it's a constant fight and a
battle for them
which really shouldn't be that way
should it
it's absolutely terrible
i can't believe it i just pronounced dad
and
i
pronounced that but holly and her family
say that if archie is to have his life
ended it should be with the dignity of
being in a garden of their choice
surrounded by nature and not the
hospital that fought his family